hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
welcome back to another vlog I'm here in
kind of country town in the middle of
Germany actually the middle of Germany
is probably alive considering very very
close to Strasbourg in France which is
probably more kind of South Germany but
anyway I'm here I actually can't even
see myself in this I don't know if I'm
in focus I don't know what the camera is
actually filming because the sunlight
here is incredible
sort of extremely humid so I'm just all
wet but we're going to have a good time
we're going to have wet and stuff
[Music]
all right today we're going to talk
about whether or not you should be using
a game engine or whether you should make
your own and in fact I think that I'm
more or less going to talk about and I'm
sorry if this is shaking this is because
I'm on a hay bale right now but you guys
know that I love to mix it up so you
know went on just such a nice day today
you know it's interesting that I'm here
in Carroll in Germany and the weather
here is incredibly hectic like I mean
there was like a bit of a thunderstorm
I think they promised a thunderstorm as
well but there was a bit of a
thunderstorm and like there was a bit of
a thunderstorm and now it's kind of gone
and it's incredibly humid and I'm just
I'm so wet man I'm so wet right and I
think now there's finally a bit of a
cool breeze so I can kind of think and
this Sun see I hate filming outside
sometimes in a day like this I'm in the
cloud the clouds are amazing here the
problem with this is the Sun is like the
sun's like in cloud out a cloud in cloud
out a cloud and I can't keep playing
with the exposure because if I keep
doing the jump cuts that it's going to
be bright dark bright dark and there's
absolutely no way I'm going to go ahead
and color correct every every single
shot you guys are just gonna have to
deal with this I mean I could probably
make it a little bit less exposed so if
you're thinking of making a game I think
probably one of the best things you can
actually do is use a game engine because
the act of making a game especially if
you're a solo developer if you're by
yourself
or if you even if you have a small team
it's incredibly difficult to make a game
from scratch in fact it's just
incredibly difficult to make a game
there's nothing there's nothing really
that easy about making a game it takes
like especially depending on the scope
of your game you might be looking at
like hundreds of people like three years
of development time games are hard
making games is something that is hard
even triple-a companies screw up games
all the time and it's not just because
of their design flaws because there's so
many technical issues you can see that
some games ship just were broken right
and then they start patching them and
fixing them like day one patch it's as
all this stuff that goes in because
making games is serious business and
it's very very difficult
so there's any chance that you can make
it easier for yourself by using
something like a game engine then of
course you're going to want to take
advantage of that it is very cool of
course to make a
yourself and to basically make a game
and be able to say this is a hundred
percent me like what you're seeing right
there I made like a hundred percent of
that I didn't just use like like some
people thinking game engines almost like
a template right where you we kind of
feel like I would like a first-person
shooter game please and I would like I
would like you to have guns it's not
really like that but of course people
are going to think that and for a lot of
people as a matter of pride it's a
matter of being able to say that this is
mine I made this and of course that's
completely silly I mean you can't like
even if it is prideful for you to be
able to do that you have to think about
it logically have to think yeah it's a
business decision right it's a business
decisions on a personal decision for you
to be like as a matter of pride I think
I would like to please make this all
myself even though it's going to take 20
times as long you can't do that you're
not going to be successful if you start
making decisions based on personal
emotions or feelings so swallowing your
pride and picking up a game engine is
probably for 95% of you the right thing
to do now I know that a lot of people on
this channel specifically are interested
in making their own game engines because
well I mean I I'm interested in making
my own game engine so if you don't know
I do work on a game engine team at
Electronic Arts so I do have quite a lot
of experience taking game engines and
even before I was employed there before
even had a software engineering job at
all I was only interested basically
making game engines but that's because I
don't want to make games games are not I
like games I like the idea of making
games I like the technology behind games
but what really excites me is that core
technology right it's it's actually the
core technology of a video game because
I don't really play that many games in
my spare time so when I see a game I
don't start immediately thinking like oh
that's some cool design decisions and
all that's some cool gameplay so I can
appreciate well put together games and I
do enjoy them however for me it's not a
matter of like I would love to make a
game like I'm much more interested in
the technology behind that and the
reason I'm telling you guys that is
because honestly I think that as a solo
or a small team of developers the only
reason you should make a game engine is
either if your game is incredibly small
or your game is incredibly focused on a
specific area that you believe from a
business point of view from a Pullman
actual like technical point of view
unity or unreal or whatever other
you want to use game maker whatever
cannot actually deliver the right
technology to you in a lot of cases that
is of course false because the game
engines are specifically designed in
mind to be kind of generalist
game making machines that are made to
suit a wide variety of genres and a wide
variety of game requirements but of
course if you have some kind of niche
that is incredibly specific making your
own game engine might be justifiable but
the idea is a game engine like licensing
costs aside I don't know why people are
concerned about like unreal 5% royalty
or unities like I don't know unity is
like per month now anyway I don't even
know what you need icing peels are
nowadays to be honest but I see people
arguing so much about like unreal 5%
royalties which i think only apply if
you make above $100,000 or something I'm
completely just talking from memory and
probably completely wrong about
everything I can just picture people
disliking this video but the fact of the
matter is like I don't know why so many
people are concerned with 5% royalties
for a game that they haven't made yet
and only if you make over 100 grand are
you seriously thinking that yeah I'm at
a I'm at a point where you know this
games going to make millions of dollars
and I need to be I need to be aware of
5% royalties no you don't like just make
a game dude make a game it's not even it
might seem harsh but success is
incredibly rare right and even if you
are successful with a game 5% it's such
a negligible amount 5% picture it this
way you've hired a team of hundreds of
developers who for several years have
worked on the core technology for your
game and in exchange you've agreed to
give them 5 percent of the money your
game makes after a certain threshold
that is an absolute steal because I can
tell you right now no matter how many
years you're going to be working on your
game engine you're never going to get up
to on-rails point and certainly not for
the cost that they're offering their
technology to you for so purely as a
business kind of tactical decision I
think it's a complete mistake it
complete mistake to like disregard game
engines based on costs or anything like
that like I mean I think you need to
picture it in terms of development time
now for those of you who are dead set on
making your own game engines because you
think that you would rather make a game
engine than a
game making games is very important if
you want to make a game engine because
your game engine is there to make games
if you don't know how to make game as
well how on earth are you going to make
a toolset for that how on earth are you
going to be able to design tools that
people who need to make games if you
don't know how they're going to be
making the games like you need to
actually know how to make games and a
really good way of finding that out is
by using you know your Unreal and it
might seem it like I've met people who
have 100% been like and I'm sure a lot
of you guys have also like this who have
been like no no I don't want to touch
you in your unreal I'm - I don't want to
become dirty with all that like I don't
know what man some some people I'm
alright I don't wanna become dirty with
all that kind of Filth I just I'm a
purist I like my own technology I'm not
gonna touch anything that's really
really stupid extra this way you're a
covert agent and you're you want to
sneak behind enemy lines to see what
kind of technology they've got so that
you can steal it for yourself that is
exactly what using other game engine is
like even if you're just focused on
making game engines you need to take a
look at unities or on Rails material
system you need to see how they set up
shaders you need to see how how they're
sprite animation system works right so
that you can get ideas for how you
should first of all design yours and B
if you think there are improvements that
you should make to your own technology
you need to be able to do that you need
to do some research into what's actually
out there to see what you can do so that
you can improve on it if you never go
out there if you never use game engines
like unity or unreal but you just focus
on your own technology that's great on
one hand but on another hand you're not
going to be able to make something good
because you you need to see what's out
there so I mean it completely baffles me
when people start saying that I don't
want to use that technology I don't want
to do that you're basically saying no to
free knowledge right and knowledge is
exactly what you're going to need if you
want to make your own game engine or
make your own anything really so if you
are focused on making game engines
definitely get out there go ahead and
open unity right now so you can download
unity or unreal they're both free for
personal use right you can download that
and you can check out all of their
technology make a game with it right now
and see what it's like to make a game
immunity and even just by using unity
like if you're designing a material
system for your own game engine
looking at the way unities works even
you don't need the source code right
just look at how their editor works look
at how they chained together like the
selector shader you have
Cheryl you have a bunch of like material
inputs whether they be textures or
constant values or even game variables
that's how their material system comes
together based on what I just said based
on what I just told you an extremely
high level overview of how you do these
materials - right okay how almost any
game engines make sure our system works
really but anyway based on what I've
just told you you can actually go out
and design a material system now right
you know exactly what it is is a shader
and it's a bunch of uniform values so
simple as that right and if you've never
looked at unity you might not even have
thought that you might be rocking some
really really weird unconventional
awkward hard to use material system that
you thought up of because you happen you
don't know better and you haven't been
through decades of game industry
experience so yeah hopefully that kind
of clears it up for you for those of you
who want to make games 100% use a game
engine for those of you who want to make
engines 100% use a game engine I'm not
being paid by unity or unreal or any
other game engine I'm not even telling
you which one I like or which one I
don't like I don't care it doesn't even
matter what engine II use unity and
unreal are the biggest ones I do have my
different preferences between game
engines which I might talk about in
another video but the point is I don't
even care what game engine you use just
go out and use a game engine because
it's going to benefit you even if you
still decide to make your own 100% gonna
benefit you anyway thanks for watching
I'm going to get off this hay bale
because it's getting a bit warm if you
guys enjoyed this video let me know what
you think of these vlogs and if you want
to see more in the future I think this
is like my fifth one I'm going to be
travelling around the area but I'm going
to the Czech Republic
like tomorrow there'll be plenty of cool
content I'm gonna try and do some vlogs
over there as well I post a lot of the
photos I take to Instagram my name is
the Cherno on instagram so definitely go
and follow me there I also tend to post
a lot of the stuff that I just do on a
daily basis as an Instagram story so
cool stuff there check it out as always
thanks for watching and I'll see you
guys in another video goodbye
[Music]
you